si vous n'êtes toujours pas vaccinées
frédéric taddeï la faute est triple en
incombe à trois acteurs premièrement le
déclin de l'industrie pharmaceutique
française puisque la france est le seul
état membre du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui n'a pas réussi à produire son
propre vaccin il n'y a pas de frais de
vaccins français pour le moment pour le
moment
sanofi et pasteurs ont lamentablement
échoué
deuxièmement vous le devez cette non
vaccination vous la devez au
gouvernement français qui a commis un
véritable naufrage logistique
vous savez que toute organisation temps
à se désorganiser à connaître des
problèmes logistiques
certains gouvernements arrive à gérer
ces problèmes d'autres pas
dans son histoire la france est la
spécialiste des grandes catastrophes
logistiques et organisationnels en 1870
face à la prusse en 1940 face à
l'allemagne
donc là on vit une nouvelle débâcle
logistiques et organisationnels et enfin
troisièmement vous le devez à l'union
européenne et à la commission européenne
qui en tant que centrale d'achats de
vaccins a elle aussi complètement échoué
[Musique]